we've seen a deadly increase in crashes
across the valley and this morning we
surpassed 100 after two people lost
their lives near red rock madison
kimbrough is live near the scenic red
rock loop with the latest details
tonight madison
nevada highway patrol has been busy this
week with two accidents and three
fatalities right here in the red rock
recreational area and unfortunately this
morning two more lives were lost both
people were from out of town
around 8 this morning a person driving
by reported that a three-wheel vehicle
had gone off the road and was on fire
the two people in the car died on scene
the scenic drive will be closed the
remainder of the day and will reopen
sometime tomorrow this happening near
red rock mile marker nine with this
crash there are now more than a hundred
traffic related fatalities compared to
this time last year the metro
jurisdiction did not hit 101 fatalities
until december 30th 2020. on wednesday
evening a motorist was traveling through
the loop north of white rock mountain
road and failed to go through the curve
in the roadway causing him to crash in
the desert that man was taken to the
hospital but later died he was 29 years
old
andrew bennett with zero fatalities
tweeted this out stating that this day
will be remembered for this 100 percent
preventable double fatal he added that
these fatal accidents are becoming the
norm we plan on talking to him directly
later tonight the red rock scenic loop
is a popular spot for drivers so it's
vital to take precaution when you are
out on these roadways reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now